from Martin Scorsese the legendary
director of that movie starring Leonardo
DiCaprio that other movie starring
Leonardo DiCaprio and also these movie
starring Leonardo DiCaprio comes the
wolf of Wall Street starring Leonardo
DiCaprio strap in for the last film
you'd ever want to watch with your
grandparents
featuring an average of 3.1 6x per
minute in $30,000
gay half-wit Betty in Hana absolutely
not
Kenny but good we can do better than
that Leonardo DiCaprio stars as a king
young hot rich guy who hangs out on King
yachts and has sex with in models
basically Leonardo DiCaprio watch as he
yells his way to an Oscar nomination
and watch as the guy who stole vests
actor stops by to pound his chest right
in Leo's face you rejoice at the
triumphant return of fat king Jonah Hill
and recoil at the triumphant debut of
his fat king penis
thrill as he tries to shed His image as
the funny fat guy in comedies by
becoming the funny fat guy in a Scorsese
movie experience the film critics can
slam for glorifying the lifestyle of a
corrupt Wall Street stockbroker even
though he's a miserable
wife-beating drug addict who loses his
business family and fortune they do make
quaaludes looking awesome though witness
coursezi breakout every Scorsese ISM in
the book like a ton of tracking shots
can voice-over see that humongous estate
down there that's my house can freeze
frames multiple wives having a
huge hard-on for New York City
and an ambitious criminal main character
with a short timbre whose pride is
ultimately his downfall so settle in for
a movie that's all about King XS from
the 3 hour runtime to the king cursing
this effect off to all the people in
suits listening to Leo talk
two shots of those same people going gig
nuts
starring two-time Oscar nominee Jonah
Hill me how I divorced your mother the
director of Ironman the director of her
the director of The Princess Bride Shane
coach Taylor Dallas Oscar Steelers club
the artist formerly known as relevant
the real Jordan Belfort because that guy
deserves a break right
and Leonardo no Oscar Oh which is crazy
when you think about all the other
people who have Oscars like three 6
mafia Al Gore Cuba Gooding jr. in Pelton
from community Suki Catwoman Marisa
Tomei Cher Nic Cage Monique American
Idol quarterfinalist Jennifer Hudson
Cadmus Roberto Benigni
twice and the movie crash the wolf of
King Wall Street sell me this pen it's
the one DiCaprio used in wolf of Wall
Street boom and easy money right there
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers execute order 66 I will find
you and I will kill you but Bubba bird
is the word I get knocked down but I get
up again you ain't never gonna keep me
down Tina come get some ham